a little bit about understanding the
earth machine learning and then a
relatively new rule tool called kupo
pipelines I'm Kyle's story a computer
vision engineer at Descartes labs and my
co-presenter I hi I'm fasting Li I'm
also computer vision engineer and with
that let's get started so we're gonna
run through a lot of things during this
talk the three key points that we hope
that you can walk away from this room
remembering are that in the domain that
we work in satellite imagery
there's an incredibly large amount and a
growing amount of satellite imagery and
it provides a very powerful way of
understanding the world around us second
machine learning is a very powerful
technique for under processing and
understanding these satellite imagery
but it presents unique challenges in
this domain and third we are using a
array of tools within the Google Cloud
suite to be able to understand these
imagery provide value for our customers
and in particular we've been exploring
coop flow pipelines that we'd like to
tell you a little bit about that today
so what do you think of when you think
of the earth what do you picture perhaps
it's this iconic picture from the Apollo
space mission of almost 50 years ago at
this point a blue dot out in space well
Oh
since that time technology has allowed
satellite in satellites to take an
increasingly large amount of data
covering our globe through a wide
variety of spectrums and over a regular
time interval and what Descartes Labs
we're in the business of taking that
massive amount of data using the Google
cloud as a backbone and processing that
into valuable information and decisions
that our customers can make so in just
to give you a sense of what we can do a
satellite imagery for example in this
picture on the left hand we have used a
particular combination of spectral bands
that pull out vegetation allow us to
understand crops crop development in the
center this is the
the synthetic aperture radar band allows
us to understand built infrastructure or
minds and minerals in the further to the
right and finally high-resolution
satellite imagery allowing us to study
and understand in this case only gas
infrastructure these are fracking
installations outside of the of active
sensors in the visible bands there are
all sort of sorry passive sensors there
are also active sensors for example here
synthetic aperture radar so this is
actually a satellite that's flying over
sending down a radar signal receiving
the reflected signal and so that allows
us to both see the reflections off of
metal structures or you can see all the
boats flowing into this harbor and also
learn about 3d information in in this
picture that all is to say that there's
an incredible amount of data that's
being produced all the time from
satellites and other sources that data
gives us a really valuable picture for
understanding the world around us and
deriving actual insights this is a
picture that was taken by the Sentinel
satellite shortly after the camp fire
erupted in Northern California in
November I you can see the plumes of
smoke coming off of the the place where
the fire is burning and by looking into
different spectral you know different
spectral wavelengths than our eye can
see we can actually pick out where the
fire is actively burning this is a
shortwave infrared and a near-infrared
false color image we can see where the
fire is act is actually actively burning
in this case and so by using satellite
energy that allows us to really
understand what's going on in our world
in in a very powerful way what's
important then is turning that massive
amount of data into decisions or
understanding that our customers can use
so here is an image of crop fields over
in centre of the United States in
Nebraska and we've built out a pipeline
that allows us to predict the amount of
corn and soy that are produced in a
given growing season and then that helps
our customers in particular cargo be
able to understand how they move grain
around and then what they can expect for
prices
the agriculture market as I mentioned
earlier on we find that computer vision
and machine learning is a very powerful
way of understanding these datasets and
being able able to produce insights at
scale and that's why the remain that's
what the remainder of this talk will
largely focus on so within within
satellite imagery and computer vision we
think about these along three axes
detect map and monitor so detect is
finding using computer vision machine
learning to be able to find
infrastructure to find the points of
interest the things that you're
interested in all around the globe Matt
you know mapping those across so mapping
those across the globe in the different
regions of interest that you're
interested in and then finally being
able to monitor those in real time being
able to understand changes and then use
that to drive your business so for an
example of detection we've built a
computer vision algorithm that can
detect wind turbines and we can now run
this anywhere in the world we're able to
use Google cloud to map all the wind
turbines in the United States overnight
mapping so this is a convolutional
neural net that maps out the footprints
of buildings and high rises resolution
satellite imagery you can see the
satellite imagery on the left and then
the output of this neural net algorithm
in the middle and on the right and then
finally monitoring change over time so
this is a pixel-based random forest
algorithm that uses the spectral
information in from the sentinel
satellite to be able to make a mask of
where water is at any time and what
you're seeing here is running that over
sequential time slices of satellite
imagery and you're seeing this reservoir
in Northern California dry up during the
the drought of the previous few years so
with that I'd like to hand over the rest
of the presentation to my co-presenter
Faustine to dig into all the things that
I've been presenting in a little more
detail thanks Kyle
so I want to preface my part of the talk
by saying we're not really all that
interested in digging into the
algorithms behind
our models if you're interested in
domain specific algorithms Kyle gave a
great talk at last year's next but for
this talk what we found as scientists
was that we really couldn't treat the
model as a black box
even though we really wanted to that
data goes in and answers come out well
what happens to the data and how does it
arrive in our model and what do we do
with the outputs where do we store it
and so forth so what we found was that
we should focus on our workflows and how
to streamline those so let me step
through this so there's a lot of things
that happen after the imagery comes off
of the satellite we have a great
ingesting that ingest data into our
platform that we built on top of Google
Cloud
but of course imagery is completely
useless if we can't access it so we host
micro services that allow scientists to
programmatically query and access
imagery and we interact with those micro
services using our deck art labs Python
library once we have training data we
time to train our model and we build
convolutional neural networks and
tensorflow and we have really leveraged
Google compute engine to train our
models and we found that deep learning
VMs are really fast to get us started
but of course now that we're ready with
our model it's time to deploy and for
large geospatial applications that often
means inference over multiple regions of
interest and we actually have a task
system that we built and host and that
allows us to scale out our models by a
hundred or thousand times and I'll talk
a little bit more about this in in depth
later so to dive in a little bit deeper
I don't want to belabor the point but
our imagery is not just pixels in fact
it's has a lot of earth science related
to it and so prior to analysis we have
to do register and co-locate all of our
imagery and we also have to care about
things like atmospheric reflectance
or weather clouds are obscuring our
objects of interest once our imagery is
analytics ready we have to access it and
because our data platform holds large
multimodal data sets we have api's that
make it really easy to access so in four
lines of Python code we get imagery over
New Mexico almost instantaneously and
this is really great for developers
because it means that if I want imagery
over a different satellite I just
changed one line of code but deployment
is where it gets tricky often we might
want every square kilometer of a very
large region of interest like the United
States so how do we do this
we have a test system that we built that
allows us to scale these highly elastic
workflows and the way we do it is we
have a client that creates tiles over
the Earth of arbitrary size and each
tile is has a hash associated with it we
have a deployment script that knows how
to instantiate a model how to predict
how to pre process and post process that
data and we feed it into our tasks API
and that all runs in kubernetes so the
earth is massively paralyzed Abal
all you have to do is ship it into
non-overlapping tiles and each tile goes
into a separate docker container and
this leverages all the really nice
things about kubernetes like auto
scaling CPU and GPU no pools things like
that but we want our results back and so
we host a catalog API we're populating
those api's that rest endpoint as we go
asynchronously so at the end you get a
map of the earth with your inference on
top of it so why are we using coop flow
well conceptually machine learning
pipelines are pretty straightforward we
get data we train a model
and then we deployed but we found that
really that's not the case and research
projects become quickly unmaintainable
and I didn't really talk about model
training because it's probably the least
inspiring part of what we do as
scientists currently we sort of manage
your own VM infrastructure we have to
manage our GT on GPUs we have to make
sure that cooed is properly installed
and so on and we spend a lot of time
debugging things like this instead of
focusing on the science and that's not
where really what we really want and
this is a really awesome thing this task
system but the deploy script is pretty
monolithic and hard to maintain and we
really want to be able to have
componentize our deployments so with
those pain pain pain points and many
more like for example we had
difficulties with managing the training
environment versus the deployment
environment and we have ran into hard to
debug bugs with that coop flow pipelines
seemed like a great option for us it was
immediately attractive because the main
points of could flow are things that we
are running into and we want to solve
internally so what is Kukla pipelines it
is a machine learning workflow there
were a machine learning system that
Vantage's machine learning workflows on
kubernetes and it aims to make machine
learning reusable and reproducible and
takes a product a machine learning
product all the way from experimentation
to deployment and of course it's runs
natively on kubernetes which is great
because all of our infrastructure runs
on the cloud on kubernetes and it works
really well with our api's so
specifically about pipelines the core
unit of work in pipelines is a operation
or component and they all run into a
docker container
and each component has an output in
input and we do graph inference so it's
a directed acyclic graph of work and it
leverages all the wonderful things about
kubernetes like auto scaling like
metrics and so on so this is kind of
what a pipeline looks like it's
basically a Python function with
operations inside and we know that this
is a pipeline because we add a little
decorator that's those DSL pipeline and
all this pipeline does is it downloads a
text file from the Google bucket and
prints it out and I'll show you this
later in the demo this is how a Google
next okay so here's the fun part
I wrote a end-to-end machine learning
pipeline in coop flow and I'm going to
demo it really soon but the application
will be detecting oil and gas sites in
the Permian Basin these are what they
look like they're called well pads if
you don't know what a well pad is
basically a large concrete rectangle
that they put equipment on while they're
drilling for oil and gas and we might be
interested in looking for these because
you know we might be interested in
monitoring where fracking activity is or
by seeing where they're being built we
can tell like monitor our energy
infrastructure so we want to turn this
into this so how do we do that
well thankfully I wrote a end-to-end
pipeline that in kupo so it goes from
pulling the imagery from our platform
from just simple labels to deploying on
our test system and seeing the output
okay so when the demo is running you'll
be able to see that this pipeline does
both training and deployment
and there's some things that we really
like about pipelines so for example each
component friends its own dock container
which means that we can encapsulate the
environment that we're working on it and
we really can control the very specific
packages that we put in it so we can
make sure that our training and
deployment environments always match and
because each component is containerized
we can mix and match components so it
promotes reuse and there's some neat
things about pipelines that I hope to
show you so they have native tensor
board integration which is really great
because you can inspect when you're
expect how your model is performing and
you can compare different runs so it
really supports the experimentation side
of model building and there's some great
things about deploying with pipelines so
it leverages all the kubernetes
infrastructure that we have in-house it
interrupts well with the tools that we
use so we heavily use stackdriver
sto and spinnaker so all those things
worked with the coop flow and managing
identities and different like workflows
with different scientists is really easy
with kubernetes like or like Google
Cloud and kubernetes authentication and
I didn't really mention this this is not
the focus of this talk but what we
really found great was that
coop flow pipelines are a first-class
citizen in a a I hub and it's a problem
internally where we get we on board new
scientists and we want to get them up to
speed and how do we do that well
previously we had to point them to a
github repo and say install these
packages run this code and it's really
awesome to be able to point to somebody
in AI hub and so download this pipeline
run it into this cluster and it's very
very straightforward now okay well I
guess I will close off this talk the
dumb was not working and contextualize
what we're trying to do in the oh well
the dumb was working so I will actually
show you this because this is really
awesome okay so this is the UI for
cupola pipelines and this is that
HelloWorld pipeline that I just showed
you from before and it's just it's as
easy as clicking a button so let's call
this run hello click start it takes a
couple seconds for kubernetes to
schedule some the pods but it should
show up very very briefly
here we go it's running looks like that
completed so let's refresh hello Google
Club next but you know that's not really
what we're here for
we're here for machine learning
workflows and this is that oil and well
pads demo you talked about earlier so
it's basically just as easy as the last
one let's call this demo I can add a
description I can add it to an
experiment let's not do that
there's some parameters that I can set
on the fly and then I can click start
and it's on its way so the idea behind
coop flow is that machine learning
should be as machine learning should be
as pain painless as possible and
previously there wasn't really great
tools like tensor flow democratized
training models but really training is
only a small part of the whole machine
learning work workflow and cycle in fact
train models just one one operation of
this multi step pipeline all right so
let's check on what our model is doing
there we go
awesome so these schemas basically are
JSON parameter files that tell each
operation certain characteristics about
the data like which satellite it should
pull from what date range it should look
for things like that and that's all we
provided to our pipeline right now it's
actually pulling imagery live from our
dead cart Labs platform and you can see
it's dreaming now and this just goes to
show how fast our data access is if you
were to try and do geospatial analysis
20 years ago you would have to work with
these very bespoke and oftentimes slow
interfaces
okay well training images complete it it
pushed it to a Google bucket so let's
check that out
there we go so our v2 images are in this
bucket we can scroll around and look at
that so very briefly the machine
learning algorithm that we're using to
train our oil and well pad detector is
what we call course segmentation so the
input images look like this so this is a
well pad and they target images look
like this so it's a binary image where
the ones are where the well pads are and
you notice that it's much much smaller
than the original target image and
that's because for simple shapes like
these well pads you don't really need
that high fidelity and because the
target image is really small these
models train much faster and you see
you'll get pretty good results with a
limited amount of data and a women in
amount of epochs to Train
so let's check in on our pipe pipeline
it will update on the fly
it looks like it's training our model
right now what we did was we pulled
imagery down from what we've created in
previous steps and it looks like it's on
epoch four and the great thing about
pipelines is that this step is training
on the GPU and as long as we have GPU
nodes available coop flow will schedule
them and what's really great is that
upgrading your GPUs to TP use is just as
transparent as adding TPU nodes to your
node pools so this should be done in a
couple minutes
epoch seven
so while that's training I can show you
very briefly what our labels look like
so this is our base satellite imagery
and these are our labels we don't have a
whole lot of them but we found that
these core segmentation segmentation
models train pretty quickly and let we
can zoom in on and take a look at some
of these well pads so this is 60
centimeter imagery over nape nape is a
from the Nagre national agricultural
program so a lot of this imagery is
abstence away for like agriculture
research so kind of zoomed in on a well
pad you can kind of see there's a little
dark spot on the center of these that's
where they put lee well when they put
the pump jack to pump the oil out okay
so I think that our training should be
close to done yeah it looks like it's
saving the model
takes a little while to upload good here
we go so let's take a look here and we
can see that it saves our model waits in
the cloud and if we go back
we can see that this metrics panel was
done so let's take a look at that and we
can open up tensor board right from coop
flow pipelines so that's great
we see that our loss went down over time
and it just launched our catalog
endpoint that's where we're store our
data and now it's launching our task
system so this will do the actual
entrance so our test takes a little
while to start up and that's just
loading a task controller making sure
that our deploy scripts in there
distributed to the worker nodes and it
takes a little bit of time to spin up
they're like to get the resources so we
can see that our tests are pending now
once that's done it should start the
inference job and it should be pretty
fast
yeah so the art cleanser Borlaug's are
available here if they're multiple in
one file you can like compare the runs
and things like that
okay so our task system says it started
and we can look at our task monitor and
see that it is indeed running so it's
already scheduling work on these nodes
and look we already have a hundred
twenty seven active workers and it's
already succeeding so as soon as this is
done we can look at the outputs and it's
going really really fast okay so that is
completed and coop low should think that
that's completed very easy all right
awesome so now this task this component
is just pulling down imagery from our
catalog product that's where we deployed
our model over and where we store our
results and this should be very quick -
so yeah and then once this is done and
we can look at our final results so yeah
this is incredibly powerful we just took
a computer vision model from no data -
deployed in less than ten minutes and
it's completely reproducible with
couplet pipelines all right awesome
this is done another neat thing about
coop flow is that you can embed
arbitrary HTML assets so here we go we
can see our a tile of what we predicted
in the results so let's take a look at
our product and this is also in viewer
and let me zoom out a little bit
okay so this is our deployed computer
vision model I can overlay the base
imagery so let me do that
and then we can compare
so it didn't it didn't train with a
whole lot of data and I didn't train
with a whole lot of epochs but it looks
like it did learn something and you know
it's really easy to start the loop back
over again add more data retrain try
different models because we've really
reduced that developer cycle real
exponentially the cupula pipelines
awesome so that was the demo we can go
back to the slides
maybe
okay so I went to Kentucky I want to
wrap up this talk and contextualize what
we're doing in in the scale of the
science that we're doing and of course
everybody likes pretty pictures so these
are projects that we've actually
deployed to scale so for example this is
all the trees in New York City mapped
and if you're interested in looking at
trees this visualization was done by our
awesome creative marketing guy Tim
Wallace he has a great medium article
available and in principle we could map
all the trees in the United States and
of course this is really useful because
we can monitor where deforestation and
reforestation is happening for something
a little bit different this is a global
no.2 map so nitrogen dioxide is a
byproduct of combustion and so this map
is really telling us where pollution is
happening you can see hotspots of where
there's like coal burning for example
and the hot spot in South Central Africa
is they do periodic vegetation burning
so this is something that you normally
can't see with the naked eye but it
becomes very visible with certain
sensors so polluters be aware we can see
you and this project shows some of the
turnaround and agility that we have at
Dickert labs so these are hundreds of
thousands of buildings over a region in
North Carolina and this was done
overnight ahead of Hurricane Florence so
that we could sort of monitor and
predict what how many buildings were at
risk just to wrap up we have a lot of
exciting science at taker labs
mostly related to the geospatial domain
and could flow pipelines is a great
resource for us because it allows us to
handle the scale and scope of our
projects our cupola also works really
great with the tools we already built on
Google cloud and it's becoming better
and better it's an open-source project
your everybody is free to support and
contribute to it and there's a lively
community already so here's a little bit
of information on how to get started
with coop flow and here's a little bit
of information about us thank you for
your thank you for your participation
that's the end of our talk
[Applause]
[Music]